Florent Pagny bienvenue chez moi voilà
on va voir
alors
alors alors alors
personne
ah ouais nanana
[Applaudissements]
et tu as un peu de son
[Musique]
quand la pluie sera
partout attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention attention
si je vous dis on va partir du côté de
Michel Sardou
Michel Sardou en chantant quand j'étais
petit garçon je repassais mes leçons en
chantant
[Applaudissements]
vous l'avez trouvé le titre préparez-les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une fille dans la rue et se dire qu'elle
est belle
attention
je crois que ça commence par le refrain
[Applaudissements]
je te donne le poids ils sont en train
de la chercher
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour faire une chanson
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
incroyable quand j'avais démarré sur le
groupe Canal+ je me rappelle au bout de
trois jours les audiences étaient on
avait fait 300000 le premier jour puis
300300000 et j'ai eu un appel de du
patron de canal
qui me dit ouais on est sur Canal+ je
pense qu'il faut que tu lèves le pied
sur les sardines
et je me rappelle j'avais dit écoute ça
sera moi ou les sardines
j'arrête à la fin de la semaine je
préfère qu'on se quitte en montant
de lever le pied sur les sardines et
sardines qui ont fait notre légende ça
va ton niveau du moral
je comprends pas je te sens partout
on va partir à côté de chez Dave
attends Vanina
on oublions on oublie pas du tout c'est
du côté de chez soi par contre toi on va
vite t'oublier dans le jardin c'est du
côté de chez soi n'importe quoi alors
non
merde [ __ ] les mecs est-ce que vous
l'avez dis-moi le premier mot
vous allez voir
[Musique]
très souvent je me demande
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
écouter des
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Nara
que je suis
[Musique]
je serai pour la vie seul au monde
[Applaudissements]
alors
les séries dur on va partir du côté de
kendji Girac les yeux de la mama
[Rires]
quand j'ai froid elle se fait lumière
elle a raison
[Musique]
le début des chansons si vous nous
rejoignez les visiteurs 52
[Musique]
quand j'ai froid elle se fait lumière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mes chansons sont souvent pour elle elle
sera toujours marron quand je ne suis
pas à la hauteur
[Applaudissements]
attention
le reste mais pas la douceur de ce geste
elle est portée avant le monde elle me
porte encore chaque seconde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez on va maintenant privilégier les
personnes âgées
à partir du côté de Michel Delpech
le chasseur
moi je l'ai
maintenant ou tais-toi
voilà alors après il faut la préparer
alors
[Applaudissements]
non on avançait dans les chemins
c'est pour toi ça couvert de brume
je vais mourir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
marchaient devant dans les roseaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lâchez les oiseaux
vers le midi
la Méditerranée
[Applaudissements]
pour Béatrice et je rappelle que
Benjamin Castaldi est ici
[Applaudissements]
il est juste là
je recherche les séries ça y est allez
on en fait
attention là dommage
début de soirée nuit de folie oh [ __ ]
alors
attention c'est pour trois points pour
trois saisons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est bon
la musique
en marchant sur une canne dans sa tête
pas tu le sens la musique au monde de
tes doigts tu dis la vie qu'on t'a donné
[Applaudissements]
attention
vous êtes éliminés
Jul on m'appelle l'ovni alors oh non
l'ovni
[Rires]
non mais là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Claude François
la pendule
[Musique]
comment faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne sais plus comment faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on avait fait que Claude François pour
Cathy donc on va devoir le refaire
François
Cathy on te fait autre chose si tu veux
le lundi au soleil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tu m'as dit je vais partir et puis tu es
parti chercher il le repos j'ai vécu
comme un robot et j'ai qu'une autre
n'est venu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi tu sonnes quand tu étais
insulte
François alors d'abord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une journée idéale pour faire quoi
jamais chaque fois c'est pareil c'est
quand on
[Applaudissements]
pour trouver le début et tout le monde
la connaît par cœur mais c'est la
première fois c'est super concept hein
je lui ai dit à 21h15
c'est déjà déposé donc voilà pourquoi
premier Gaou de Magic System quoi
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez remarqué j'aimerais
qu'on revienne sur quelqu'un sur une
attitude
que vous avez remarqué chez vous ici
personne ne payait pour danser
est-ce que vous avez remarqué l'attitude
de Raymond qui est un petit peu en
retrait genre je suis un petit peu c'est
un peu le job de
amusez-nous le truc c'est toi c'est mon
truc c'est mon jeu
par exemple
Claude Barzotti je ne t'écrirai plus ah
j'adore alors [ __ ] ah c'est du niveau
à quelle heure à ça
ne voulait mais ne voulez pas
c'est la première fois que tu dis ça
[Rires]
[Musique]
alors là le problème qu'on a c'est même
on l'entendant on peut pas la ressortir
ce qu'il a dit non
je t'enverrai la tendresse de Bernard
jamais rien compris ah ouais je t'ai
envoyé des choses
je t'envoyais des fleurs séchées de la
lavande et des pensées il n'y a pas
d'amour heureux les états
[Applaudissements]
je ne t'écris plus maintenant tout va
bien
[Applaudissements]
tu peux laisser ça s'il vous plaît
l'histoire c'est la dernière chanson qui
passe au Rambo à Mykonos quand il est 6h
du matin
on va fermer la lumière
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la grande gagnante pour moi c'est
Delphine
[Applaudissements]